anytime I'm inside the cave I feel I'm
in a different time scale above the
ground is much faster the tree grows and
dies in like hundred years but inside
the caves it's millions of years and
it's timeless
eleven miles north of Beirut hidden
inside a mountain lies the Jeita grotto
the pride of Lebanon and one of the most
majestic caves in the world when we say
sheep a cave everybody knows yet I gave
it's a very important cave because it's
the main water source of Beirut and area
Nevada would a small portion of the Jada
grotto is open to the public
the rest is accessible only to a select
few including this billiard club founded
in 1951 it's the oldest most respected
caving Club in the Middle East this
particular Billabong was founded during
the explorations of Jada grotto the same
history of our club is the history of
Jada grotto every week this billiard
club gets together and girls caving in
The Grocer
when they explored they travel by birch
down a subterranean Black Lake their
mission is to discover new caves map
them photograph them and ultimately
protect them there's no doubt that she
thought greater is really a work of art
simply because of its huge scale and
it's huge formations and those
formations aren't set in stone the cave
is very much alive all of this is still
under growing it's not a fossil cave yet
still living this cave in the last 65
years the Spiller Club has discovered
over 600 caves every weekend their work
goes on we can say that we had explored
all Jetta cave because it's two years or
one years we discovered new things so we
are still working inside Jetta and we
will not finish
you